you fought chuckled down chuck liddell
when i was growing up the iceman was the
like i mean he was untouchable and then
he got touched and he seemed to never be
the same fighter again and the same
thing happened with roy jones i was the
greatest of all time tarver hit him with
the overhand right and he was never the
same fighter again
do you think the concept of being a shot
fighter is a real thing do you think
you'd lose a step and then the follow-up
to that is do you think mcgregor's ever
going to be the same guy ever again
where's the book out uh you can't you
can't lose a step for sure 100 you know
a lot of guys when they take a big shot
like that you know it's all about doing
the right rehab you know when you don't
get your neck and everything looked at
and you don't you know um
restore the body give yourself enough
time off then that button is easier to
press you know but then at a certain age
you know it's easier to turn that button
off so
you you only have so many fights in you
you know and you and if you take too
many shots too early then that fight is
it the actual shots is it is it that the
you lose that that air of invincibility
people aren't as afraid to come after
you is it you actually lose a physical
step or you had a hole there the whole
time like maybe roy jones had that
overhand right hold the whole time just
nobody threw it before tarver it's just
what happens that these guys are
untouchable and then all of a sudden
three four five losses in a row it's a
combination of everything you know it's
a part of the fact that they can't take
a shot then it's an another part of the
fact that they're not used to taking a
shot and then you know when you do get
hit with a shot you kind of go into
panic mode because you're not used to
that or you start having those thoughts
running your mind like oh [ __ ] now this
happened again you know you start to to
start to worry about it and um you know
you're not able to recover so it's a
combination of of different things so
when you look at a guy like mcgregor is
the book out on him does he need to
completely re redesign his training
module or is it is it just time he had
his run and it's over i think he can he
can rebuild you know i'm looking at
mcgregor now have you guys seen mcgregor
now massive oh my gosh he's he's big
he's big there's no there's no water i
guess or anything like that going on i
don't know i mean he's still in the
testing pool so he has to be doing
everything legal i don't know how he's i
don't know what he looks like he's
trying to fight in the heavyweight looks
like he's a gorilla yeah i mean listen
if he's still trying to fight 155 i
don't know how he's going to make that
weight not going to happen no he he's
really massive right now what do you
think he weighs right now 180 something
yeah maybe 190 i mean he's got he's got
like that
that built where his shoulders look like
it's hard to wipe his ass
so you would know i do know what you're
saying
but i mean it's a
i think he can do i mean if anybody if
anybody who can come back and do it as
mcgregor because mcgregor has he was
propelled by belief you know what i'm
saying he's one of those guys who you
know was like the ali he said it and he
went out and did it so he can do that
again so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]